artificial intelligence has seen
significant growth in recent years due
to advancements in hardware and software
Technologies the use of AI in Industries
such as autonomous vehicles Smart Home
Technology and customer service chatbots
has become increasingly relevant leading
to more efficient processes
AI startups raised 21.5 billion dollars
in the Venture Capital funding in 2020
up from 16.5 billion dollars in 2019. in
addition major tech companies such as
Amazon Google and Microsoft are
investing billions of dollars into AI
research and development the salary of
an AI engineer in the United States is
106 000 as per Glassdoor these numbers
demonstrate the rapid growth of AI and
its increasing importance in our lives
and the global economies
so are you ready to take your career to
the next level simply learns artificial
intelligence Masters program in
collaboration with IBM introduces
students to the Blended learning and
prepares them to be specialist in Ai and
data science
this program will teach you the
necessary skills you need to become an
expert and land your dream job this
master's program covers first applied
data science with python this course
covers python libraries for data science
statistics data wrangling feature
engineering Etc the next course is
machine learning
in this course we will cover supervised
learning regression and classification
decision trees and random Forest
other topics like time series modeling
level up sessions and more next is deep
learning with carers and tensorflow in
this course we will learn recurrent
neural networks restricted boltzmann
machines autoencoders Etc
the next course is AI Capstone project
in this course we will learn model
building and fitting exploratory data
analysis Etc
along with all these there are many
other topics and Concepts that will be
covered in this artificial intelligence
Masters program so what else can you
expect from this program so this program
includes three Capstone and 12 industry
relevant projects from the likes of
Amazon Walmart Mercedes-Benz Uber and
many more immersive learning experience
8X High Life interaction in the AI
online classes labeled by seasoned
trainers and Industry experts and simply
learns job assist program now what is
this job assist program simply learns
job assist program is an india-specific
offering in partnership with imjobs.com
to help you land your dream job with the
job assist program we will offer
extended support for the certified
Learners who are looking for a job
switch or starting with the first job
upon successful completion of this
artificial intelligence course you will
be eligible to apply for this program
and your details will be shared with IM
jobs as a part of this program IM jobs
will offer IIM jobs Pro membership for
six months resume building assistance
career mentoring and interview
preparation sessions via webinars and
Career Fairs the online training will
give you hands-on experience with real
world projects games prediction models
logic constraints satisfaction concerns
experience and understanding systems
probabilistic models and agent decision
making skills using artificial
intelligence machines and models you
will also learn data wrangling data
exploration data visualization
hypothesis creation and testing
procedures in data science
you will also get hands-on experience
with numpy Keras are tensorflow vendors
and many more this simply learned an IBM
collaborated artificial intelligence
course combines AI data science machine
learning and deep learning allowing for
the real world application of tools and
models
completion of this master's program you
will receive certificates from IBM and
simply learn for the AI courses in the
learning path these certificates will
testify to your skills as an expert in
the artificial intelligence so what are
you waiting for don't miss out on this
chance to take your career to the next
level enroll in our artificial
intelligence Masters program course
today and start your journey to become
an AI expert the link is in the
description box and comment section
below
thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here